hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig today we have a very
exciting episode
chris clemons is here youtuber
designer um weed smoker
uh rosie o'donnell cosplayer
christy teigen lettuce giver you know
him you love him and if you don't get
ready
you're going to love him we talk about
his whole youtube journey we talk about
his chance encounters
with uh random celebrities like chrissy
teigen and rosie o'donnell and we talk
about his recent covet scare and
everything
in between it was a great time i enjoyed
every second of it i learned that you
can dm
people on tick tock which i didn't know
before but you'll hear all about it
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
chris commons
all right we are here
with famed rosie o'donnell cosplayer
chris
clavins oh my god you are fresh on your
research uh no i have so many questions
you've had
a wild last couple of weeks to say the
least sir how are you doing and i was
like oh right right
everything happened everything happened
i honestly just feel nothing
i like i don't
it's what okay so for people that don't
know
can you give us a brief overview in your
words of this adventure or misadventure
that you've been on the last couple
weeks
yes so about two weeks ago
three weeks ago i really could not tell
you i
was going i have not really been doing
anything
for the last nine months i've really
been home i've really been you know
doing my part yeah this is what i
appreciate about you
is that you are i like to say minding
your p's and q's you're minding your
pandemic and quarantine
right now and i appreciate it because
a lot of people in the social influencer
type of world that are not doing that so
you're doing a great job
and um the hype house name names jacob
yeah yeah anyway um so i was going i got
this
i was talking to this person who
we had basically i basically like shot
my shot and was like yo would you want
to film a video together
because we were mutuals on tick tock and
i was like
why the [ __ ] did that even happen and
why is that a sense that's coming out of
my mouth
and so i was like okay you're getting
tested daily because they were on sets
for [ __ ] and so i was like okay or and i
was like do you mind if we
get tested before because that's the
only way i will have peace of mind
yeah and so for me i was so it was the
morning
of the day we were gonna shoot and it
was like a wednesday so i wake up that
morning i take a hot shower i'm like
oh like woohoo yeah so i i
film in the car because i'm like i want
a show getting tested i think it's good
to talk about i think
like if i'm gonna do something like this
i want to show that
i wasn't just out here free ball in it
you know
totally and i think people i have
friends that
i've been tested multiple times over the
last few months
and a lot of people that haven't think
it's this much more complicated thing to
do than it is
no it is a spa treatment at this point
this is like
my facial this is like oh
i get tested and i'm like stick it up
there i
i and this is coming from someone who
was like horrified
of like the nose the idea of a nose swab
i was like
no they're putting chips in our brains
like at the beginning i was like i mean
who the [ __ ] knows what's happening
um i mean obviously that q anon thought
went out the window
um but i
was just like i really honestly enjoy it
so i
was like let's show it all of this i was
even making jokes like this is gonna be
awkward if i come back positive but
there's nothing i can even think about
so then i comes back positive and i
was like like
well i've got like you've been tested so
many times gotten so many negatives i
was like
this one's in the bag uh-huh i was
so yeah i got up the guy was like you're
positive i mean it's all on [ __ ]
footage it's like all
documented and i was like can you do
another one and
he was like yeah sure um so then that
one came back positive and so i like
went home
my roommate andrew was like i have never
heard you
sound like that like you sounded like
the mother from hereditary
i was like first of all what
um so then i was thinking about it
though
and it just wasn't adding up and i was
so
afraid of posting the original video
where i was like i
so i got home and i was like i should
film something really quick in case
this escalates insanely like i don't
want to just disappear
it i don't [ __ ] know a lot of
unanswered questions yeah
yeah so i just recorded like a hey if i
go missing i'm
you know um and then so i just it wasn't
making sense so i was like let me go get
a few non-rapid tests because obviously
rapid testing
is pretty inaccurate as i've discovered
and i got a bunch of tests done
that day that all came back negative
wow and
it's wild but that see the same thing
happened to mamrie
we were set to she heard me yeah we were
set to record and we've already talked
about this on our podcast so it's okay
for me to say it here but
we were set to record one day and she
called me in the morning
so sobbing upset i've never seen
hereditary but probably the mom from
hereditary
and i've only seen 15 minutes but
based off of the 15 minutes i was like
not a good sign got it
uh and then yeah she immediately made
like another appointment the next day
and then made another rapid appointment
and both of those came back negative
uh because same for her like my test
came back negative we're in each other's
bubble
and so all of the things just didn't add
up that everyone around her her
boyfriend was negative like all of this
stuff
and so she went and got two more tests
both came back negative still like
quarantined for like a week or
two and uh and yeah but it was wild like
emotional
rollercoaster to the max emotional
rollercoaster doesn't even
like be like i would rather have an
emotional roller coaster than that that
was
i literally felt like i got like a death
sentence and i know that that's probably
so offensive to
everybody with a death sentence but like
it just felt
end of the world it's like i it's not
like i've been going to [ __ ] saddle
ranch or any of this [ __ ] like i barely
go to the grocery store i feel
like yeah so i just it's a lot like when
you get bed bugs
that you're like i didn't do anything
necessarily wrong
to get these things but i feel dirty now
and i
everyone near me is uh has a possibility
of having them somewhere in their either
yeah literally yeah but i think that's
really good
has the feedback on your whole journey
been
uh relatively positive my journey yes
um uh yeah i thought i was honestly
gonna get cancelled and i don't know if
that's just like my paranoia or whatever
because i
i figured that being positive no we'll
get it
well for a few things i'm just paranoid
i'm kind like i'm just so scared of the
[ __ ] internet
um i was just afraid of like if i came
back positive people would be like oh
he's
not been following the rules and [ __ ]
like that i was afraid that
oh he's docky or he's um
capitalizing off of corona and getting
and so
there was just so many things that like
because i care about being
a good person and right
you don't want your intentions to be
misconstrued and not
at all it's impossible to prove
intentions
to strangers that watch you on the
internet exactly
so i was honestly really scared but
everybody was so
nice everybody it was like shocking
i felt like it was like my birthday all
over people were sending me edible
arrangements i was like [ __ ] i would
have done this
months ago and then you're like should i
feel bad for this and am i gonna get
cancelled for
having an okay outcome out of this
that's when i was like oh my god
yeah it was very weird i'm so happy it's
like behind me though
par for the course this year it seems
very in line well now let's go let's go
back in time because i want to hear a
little bit about your story of how you
came
to be in this position in which you're
documenting yourself
uh you went to college at nyu
yeah okay and you went for photography
i majored in photography and minored in
this thing called media culture and
communications it's
cool just it was like a legitimate thing
for me to do
because i was majoring in photography
sure give you a little grounding
now exactly is that when you got
interested
in the internet like how did that start
so i
have like always been interested in the
internet
i just was always i think afraid to
admit it when i was younger
or like because i mean i grew up being
like don't make friends online don't do
and i was like literally doing
every opposite thing like yeah it's so
funny even talking about this now
because
that conversation is so different like
kids don't get the
the internet was so scary when we were
younger so scary
and also like so um
like secret dorky adventure like
it wasn't cool yeah i remember
like having a youtube channel and not
having told anybody for like
a year uh-huh and so i had always like
fail i had like disposable cameras
growing up
and video camcorders and i just loved
filming and making [ __ ] taking pictures
like it did not matter i just loved it
yeah and so then i remember obviously
watching our queen i justine
and it was like back in her like apple
store dancing like
just iconic like the old ass
huge like so pure so pure
pure and i watched these and i was like
i almost
wanted to upload all these things i was
making they were just like stop motions
it wasn't even like me but i was like
i don't want to get bullied i don't want
people to find it like
holy [ __ ] and so i just always like
watched people
and then i
was a freshman in college and i was an
extra on the wolf of wall street for the
last
month of my first semester semester of
college yeah it was like
i thought i was literally leonardo
dicaprio
and they were like extra number 812
thank you i have a costume amazing
but i was on set for like 16 hour days
like all of this [ __ ]
and i got home to winter break like the
day after
it's we stopped and i was in delaware
and i was
bored out of my mind i was like holy
[ __ ] this is gonna be a long
five weeks yeah and so one of my friends
was like dude you have a nice camera
from going to school from photography
why don't
have you ever thought about like making
a youtube channel i was like that's
funny because i have and so then i just
decided to do it
and that's when it all began yeah it's
so
like awkward looking back people are
like oh what did you start doing and i
was like
the about me tag i don't know why yeah
no
way to feel like you're part of
something there's a template already
created
yeah so it's um yeah i just kind of
fell into it with boredom is that also
where you started doing like man on the
street type of things so i feel like
that's when
and correct me if i'm wrong things
started to like get momentum for you
no that really is like i so i just i
wanted to do a video
i always done like dumb sketches or
um like pranks even
that's okay you're in a safe space
uh i one day was like oh i want to ask
old people
pop culture slang and so i went to times
square i bought this like microphone had
no idea what i was doing
and i went to times square of all places
in the dead
of january and i was like do you know
what twerk means
and but i just had such a fun time it
was the best and so then
i really kind of dove into just
interviewing strangers i
in new york i know you know because you
get there it
i mean the people there are unmatched
yeah they're so authentically unique
it's why they don't give a [ __ ]
and so i just i would ask people their
strangest sex stories i would look at
justin bieber's nudes like i we just did
anything and everything and it was just
fun it was like literally fun yeah and
then i moved out to la and i was like
i didn't say it i did not say that but
no it it just changed a little because i
was like i'm doing one thing i want to
make sure i'm not just like a one-trick
pony
sure kind of thing so then i kind of got
away from it and now i'm doing none
but you're doing so much more now and i
feel like that
helped you figure out one like a world
of comedy that maybe you wouldn't have
found previously because did you finish
your degree or did you
stop school i finished hell yeah
hell yeah i was like i can't be another
youtuber without a college
to go to degree like nyu i always
fantasized about
was like this incredible school that the
olsons were at and so it was like
this mystical two it's funny because me
too
what was your actual if you could
summarize like
what your actual nyu experience was like
it was it's
so hard i like i i'm thinking about like
because all of my other friends like
pretty much went to like the typical
college experience when i would visit
them i was like [ __ ] i wish i had this
it's like the total opposite like yeah
you get a fake id at 18
you're like not going to frat parties
you're going to like bars with like
adults uh-huh um it's i like didn't
really
i know i went to class but like there's
just so many opportunities and that's
what i really saw
like college as not as much like school
which i know is like horrible but i
was just like i was from delaware so i
was like i have the world at my
fingertips with no one telling me i
can't do [ __ ] like
let's go so i would sometimes miss class
i had jobs
um i was working all throughout college
it's that's cool though because that's
part of i imagine the nyu experience
is the experience of living in new york
city itself
a hundred percent it was it was so
awesome
to just have full independence and feel
like you really have the world
at your fingertips because new york is
so diverse but it was weird because i
feel like i had to like
grow up yeah you're trust in it yeah
you're like i was looking for an
internship freshman year when my friends
were like yeah i'm thinking of getting
an internship junior year and i'm like
wait what
yeah so it was it was definitely weird
and i didn't really relate to a lot of
other college friends but it was fun
like i
yeah it allowed me to be here so
incredible now
you also worked at nyu's telemarketing
company is that true
oh that is true i did write down a dina
menzel's number
what okay wait what is this what were
you doing and do you have oh no i think
that's like
super illegal um yeah i was like calling
like alumni to be like
hey i know you're in super debt but like
donate it was like the craziest job to
put [ __ ] like 20 year olds up to it
was horrible
that's the scheme that's how they do it
they get the students to call the peop
the alumni to see if they can shake some
change out of them
i'm like no no no i should be the
supervisor for the people calling and
saying that's not the experience
i'm like who is this stranger telling me
i didn't do a good enough phone call
oh i love it now at what point did you
in like all of this content creation
take that on and decide like this is
going to be your full-time
gig was there a moment or is it kind of
just naturally
when i got let go for my job um
no so i had a full-time job
three months before graduating where
basically when i wasn't in class i would
go into the office it was like a tech
startup where we made apps
and websites for like celebrities
influencers et cetera that they were
kind of like blogs
it's not important the companies i don't
even know why i'm talking about it
but i had a job and so i was with that
for a year and a half and i was
i there was a co-worker who had lived in
like japan
and worked remotely for a year or
something and i was like hey could i
move to la and
for six months and like test out because
i've always wanted to see if i want to
live in l.a like
can i go there and work remotely because
like my job was
would have actually like me moving here
made a lot of sense because it was
trying to get people i knew and other
people in the space to
want an app or a website so my my ceo
was like
yeah absolutely and so i kind of had the
idea at the end of the six months to
like
quit but then in october i got let go
and i was like oh
and then i got two months of severance
so i was like this worked out perfectly
yeah everything's coming up crisp and so
then yeah i
really was like okay i guess we're just
doing youtube now
cool okay we're gonna take one quick
break and when we get back i want to
talk about the clothing brand i have
lots of
questions and it's very cool so we'll be
right back thank you
with more not too deep
[Music]
not too
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two
things a big thank you for listening to
the podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank
you and uh second thing if you are
enjoying yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise maybe just good
or otherwise would be appreciated other
than that enjoy the podcast
uh okay talk to me about middle kid this
is your clothing brand
yes it's very cool i'm also a middle kid
so i i don't know i have to send you
[ __ ]
please this is a passive aggressive ask
um
this is a very active uh receive
thank you now how did this start and how
long have you been doing this
so i like i feel like i
remember having like two dreams in life
one to like be an entertainer at the
time i thought it was acting
thank god that i came to realize that
that wasn't it
and then another one was like designing
and making clothes
um i don't i do not know why but i would
there's a craft store in delaware called
ac moore
i know it's like a chain oh my god you
know of it i'm from jersey yeah we had
ac more
for sure oh my god it closed down since
don't want to talk about it but i would
always get these t-shirts and like
i don't even think it was like fabric
paint it was like acrylic paint but i
would just iron [ __ ] on
glue stuff cut and sew i just did
whatever i was like there are no rules
yeah you did a little episode of project
runway by yourself
fully by myself i played all the
characters like designers
and i just i remember being like it
would be so
cool if i could design clothes and
people would buy them and then i was
like i don't know how that'll ever
happen i'm in delaware
like i remember having that thought and
so
as like youtube started to do whatever
it did um you know
like a good old little youtuber i was
like merch yeah
yeah so i made merch and then i had this
realization of
why am i putting my name why am i
putting my face like
i was thinking about it and this is so
bad but like joey graceffa i remember
had this like teal t-shirt with a giant
thing of his face on it
yes and i was like i just looked at it i
was like
no this is gonna sound so [ __ ] it was
just how my i was like
who would buy that and then want to wear
that all the time it's like a concert
t-shirt it's like
i don't wear it's like i bought four
hillary duff t-shirts one at every
concert and i never wore them
yeah yeah and so i was like okay so
maybe the angle to merch
is what if i design
stuff that people knew was mine but it
would be something that they'd pick up
and at the time it was
on an urban outfitters t-shirt table i
was like what is something like that
and so then i designed a whole bunch of
t-shirts
um no chris clemons no anything
and they like blew up like i didn't even
go to i wasn't even like invited to
vidcon i was in new york when vidcon was
happening and my shirt sold out
three separate times they had to like
rush order john and i was like
cool and so yeah it was like
i mean it was like i felt like steve i
imagine steve jobs feeling i was like i
have invented
the computer yeah like people have never
worn clothing until this moment
literally i cannot believe i invented it
um
and so that was a huge like holy [ __ ]
factor of pursuing the clothing and now
i just
i changed the name since then i'm
obviously a middle kid too and i wanted
something that reflected
me but was still cool and something that
i could like think about
seeing maybe on a rack in the dream
store i'd want this
in and so i kind of was thinking of
names that would last
and would still kind of hold their own
and i
could look cool as just a logo on a
t-shirt um totally
and so now i'm getting into really
custom designs like these
trucker hats we fully uh
made custom my head is very large and so
i look so stupid in a lot of [ __ ] but
with like
these and like the bucket hats i have
gotten so
much feet like it took so long but so
many of my friends
people i trust are like this hat
what the hell and i i'm like i've
invented
clothing again i did it again
so it's i don't know it's just always
been something that i've always made
sure that i like
was enjoying yeah
do you design all of the this the
clothing and
accessories yourself yeah so i
yeah before it was just like doing like
the graphics on it and stuff but now
like i said we're designing i'm like
building the actual like right now i'm
working on hoodies which has taken me
the longest [ __ ] time
um but it's like i'm like building the
shape of the hoodie
and the colors and all of that so it is
it's just
it's exactly what i wanted to be doing
well okay you're in line with all of
that your
house is coming together and looks
gorgeous
is interior design a world that you want
middle kid to uh advance into
oh my god i would like literally die for
that
yeah really yeah i i really
i anything creative i feel that
besides singing or like just music
as a whole yeah i i really
gravitate towards but especially like
design and
aesthetic like curating an aesthetic and
stuff i feel like i really have a good
strong suit for so when we moved into
this house
um i just i was like this is the most
space i've ever had
and i just i and i mean we're in
quarantine so i mean i've just been
[ __ ] going yeah at furniture stores
like online and stuff
it was really stressful buying furniture
online oh yeah
i it's a gamble it's a gamble i also
love i saw in your video that you
um do your
uh dishes in your bathroom
was that in your vlog that was
i was like this is a curious moment that
he's kind of glossing over real quick
i'm i'm psych i'm like
crazy i'm not that crazy i that was just
for corona when i
uh so i was just quarantining in my room
and i was like
look at my bathroom i wash my dishes in
it now
i just thought people would be like what
was your setup i i don't [ __ ] know it
no i loved it but i was just that makes
so much more sense but
when i was watching it i was like hold
on are we gonna just move on from him
watching his dishes no that's a
very that's a very fair question for you
to bring up
that is i did not even consider that
well okay let's talk a living situation
you have a roommate andrew
how long have you guys lived together
we've lived together
um three and a half four
no not three and a half like two three
years
a good amount of time a long time yeah
and what are your
like have you developed any roommate
tips for people
that are figuring out how to cohabitate
with a friend
um i think like
bound like honest boundaries
and or upfront boundaries and then
honest communication
like honest communication is not easy
yeah i mean it is easy now that i'm like
27 but like when i was
23 or 20 sharing apartments with people
i was like
oh i'm such a people pleaser so i was
like i don't want i'm like no
leave your dirty dishes on my bed like
like i had uh
i've had roommates who like just i was
like i let do
crazy [ __ ] cuz i was like too afraid of
confrontation yeah i'm with you well
it's like i'm not normally afraid of
confrontation i feel but when it's in
your own house and you live there and
stuff it's like you don't
want that to be lingering like at least
i don't
totally so honestly like andrew and i
are just so
open with each other we're like hey that
was annoying or like hey could we make
sure we do that
or you just can't yeah
just like don't take it as personally as
it feels it's just like a little
like uh it's like a little note yeah
yeah yeah
you know um let's talk about a different
andrew
you interviewed andre yang
i think the really cool thing that you
do is that you are
very uh outspoken about you know social
issues
and you are your own type of activist
and you
you had an interview with andrew yang
which is so cool like
how do you balance like doing funny dumb
stuff
on the internet and then like speaking
out about like
real injustices because i know like
myself
and a lot of people this year especially
have struggled with finding that
balance you know what i'm curious how
you approach it
i don't know i like i just have kind
of this is the first time that i've
really like in 2016 was probably the
first election that i
really like paid attention to obviously
like same
when obama that was like huge in its own
way but i wasn't in the nitty-gritty of
policies and this and that
but 2016 was like the big one so after
the last four years i've kind of been
not dulled down to all of this but like
it's just
i don't i didn't feel like i had that
same vigor of like
like where but wait chris where are you
going with this
sorry i just have a habit of like just
talking
i love it no i i don't have like a
guideline that i keep i think you can be
crazy and silly and a total joke
while also being able to have an opinion
and to have
a moral compass and confidence in that
and so for me i was like i may not say
the right things and a lot of times
especially on twitter i've had to like
just
literally not go on there because i just
you get so angry
and like well i do i get so angry and i
just like scream
and i'm like i haven't really thought
that through so i
so it's like a lot of tweeting and
deleting but i think a lot of is just
knowing like i have been really
practicing getting confident
with like myself and just knowing like
i firmly believe that this is right and
that is wrong
and it's just and then just saying that
i feel
i i feel like i just it was something i
had to step up to the plate and do
because it would be
dumb not to yeah no i agree with you and
i feel
i've done a lot of listening and
educating myself this year
and also like knowing that
no one needs my opinion on things
sometimes
and that's really nice to reconcile
yourself with
so nice to reconcile with oh yeah hugely
um but i think it's really cool that you
make that
without intentionally trying to but you
like it is part of what you're doing
online i think it
helps normalize those kind of
conversations for people that
think of social media as just this like
aesthetic
vibe like kind of [ __ ] totally totally
and i think it also
i i feel like it really just
differentiates
a whole lot of people who are just
willing to put their neck on the line
rather than just upkeep
this fame and lifestyle and you know i
just i think it yeah
it gives a level of seriousness that i
want to be taken with as a person of
just
i'm not yeah i can be funny and i can
make you piss your pants
and whatnot but like at the end of the
day i still am able to also sit down and
have a very serious conversation about
x y and z if i want to yeah how do you
and maybe this is something it sounds
like you still work on
how do you respond to trolls do you find
yourself responding more to trolls
this year or pulling back a little bit
or it's all over the place
it really depends on how much i've
smoked
if we're just gonna get into it um
i i don't know i and definitely
i'll fill in the bubbles still working
on it yeah yeah they're just
i'm sure you get it it's like some
sometimes people [ __ ] comment stuff
and you're like
it does it's like just it doesn't even
matter but it's like
oh you just yeah you're like i think you
i know if you get
caught in a vulnerable moment and then
you hate yourself for it
later and you're like why couldn't i
just control myself
and yeah it's tough yeah and so
yeah well
sorry sometimes you just want to like
pone someone in the comments you just
want to be like [ __ ] you
everyone look at this now
uh what's your go-to or favorite
social media platform do you have one
um all of them no um
not twitter instagram used to be
but like just i'm seeing too many dumb
people there
i'm really like finding and i can't
believe i'm saying this out loud um
yeah i love tik tok
except it has started a complex where
i'm starting to feel really
old and i never thought that i would
feel that way i was like i can't wait to
be in my 30s like i can't wait to be
40. like now i'm like i want to be used
to 18 again
everybody's like so pretty and talented
and like
springy and like they all have great
ideas
seemingly all the time it is exhausting
it is what it's wonderful to see and
it's so
frustrating at the same time um
but with okay let's talk about with
these social media platforms you've
uh accidentally created some chance
encounters with some
uh high-ranking celebrities in the
entertainment industry
let's talk about the chrissy teigen
exchange
can we talk about that one right because
that's forgot about that one
unless we not forget that's how your
pandemic started that was day 10. i
remember the instagram caption
day 10 of quarantine wait okay so give
us
for anyone that doesn't know this
beautiful anecdote can you give a brief
version of it yeah brief being the key
word i heard yeah
um basically chrissy tegan was like
anybody have romaine lettuce
it was like back when everybody was like
stockpiling food
yeah at the beginning of the pandemic
she's like anybody got romaine i will
give you banana bread
i had just seen it i don't know why i
just i was looking to feel something i
guess
i sprinted from my bedroom into the
kitchen because i
just bought romaine i was like oh my god
here we go
i don't even like i loved chrissy's
tweets and all but like i was
i wouldn't even consider myself like a a
fanboy of her like i would
just i thought she was funny on twitter
yeah i don't know
what compelled me but she literally saw
it was
we just exchanged a bunch online of like
funny jokes dms and stuff
and then we met up in a church parking
lot where
i gave her three trader joe's
heads of romaine and she gave me
she and john legend by the way gave pull
up in their all
blacked out range rover they gave me
banana half a banana bread because john
had to eat the other half
a bottle of john's wine um they ordered
us vegan food because she thought we
were vegan
and then what else did they throw in
there there was something else
wow i was like what just
what the [ __ ] just happened and of all
places the church parking lot
it really sealed the deal yeah a real
religious experience for you
she took me to church also
uh giving someone romaine lettuce to me
is like very brave because lettuce is
can be good or bad and that's a very
brave move
that's i mean that's that's what i'm
[ __ ] my pants around like what if i
get there and she's like ew this is
trash so are you
like i just you know in those scenarios
you're i don't i didn't think she was
mean or anything but you know
i just went to the absolute worst case
like this has e coli
like i just any i've ruined john
legend's entire career
he'll never recover i literally i was
like
i don't know if [ __ ] romaine is good
or bad i haven't bought groceries in so
long
i'm like oh my god oh i love it
the um yeah it was quite a sight uh
mamrie was upset because she really
wanted to get in there about it and i
think you snuck in before her which is
very funny
so sorry names and then most recently
the one and only rosie o'donnell has uh
recognized you
on tick-tock which should hopefully make
you feel a little young
or old that you have this amount of
emotion about rosie o'donnell
that's kind of the latter is definitely
how i've been feeling especially seeing
how
few people had to like who knew who she
was yeah
um so that was alarming but i
are you kidding me have you literally an
icon
have you exchanged any messages or
anything or it's just been
i dm'd on tick-tock and she has not
responded
we will see in my defense i don't know
if she knows
the whole dm'ing on tick tock i didn't
even know that you could dm on tick tock
so i mean
there we go but she left a few comments
she approved of my rosie o'donnell
outfit which i was like
i felt so bad though because i was like
[ __ ] i hope she doesn't think i'm like
bullying her
i just like genuinely see this outfit in
the reflection and i'm like
rosie o'donnell 100 yeah and she saw it
too
and she had a great sense of humor about
it which is like
such a good set i know i mean at this
rate
who's next well the person i was
supposed to film a video with when the
whole corona thing happened
was a celebrity on tick tock
oh not jason derulo don't worry um
talk about out of place um
yeah so that's that's who's next and i'm
trying not to reveal it because i'm
any other dream collabs or chance
meetups that you would like
with celebrities that we should know
about because
you seem to be manifesting these things
i really
i really do um who would be like a dream
i'm trying to do something with like joe
biden um
so i was working with the dnc a lot
that's how the andrew yang
interview came about and he's joe's from
delaware i saw him vote he lived right
next to my high school so like
it's all there yeah he's we i just think
it would be like a nice full circle
thing
for me but um
i really i i am so bad at questions like
this because i know
anybody i could think of is like we'll
we'll keep it at joe and we'll manifest
that and we'll see where that takes us
absolutely
we're going to take one last break when
we get back i have a bunch of instagram
questions for you so we'll be right back
we're not too deep
okay before we get into these instagram
questions i'm going to ask you the two
questions
ask every single guest that's on the
podcast the first is who
alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti
at called spaghetti ivanka
oh that's a good one yeah while she's in
her little uh
seat while she's in the little chair
deposition chair i hate that [ __ ] oh
it's a lot of feelings there her
oh my god i know my boyfriend can't look
at jared kushner's face it gives him
like a very physical
oh my god that is jared kushner never
mind
yeah yeah okay uh the next question i
ask every single guest and a lot of
people had already dm me saying that
they already know this story of yours
but
i ask every guest to tell us their worst
pant [ __ ] story
or a close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases
to describe your story so mine for
example
is college jogging front lawn
okay mine is it's on youtube
perfect all right no it's like literally
on youtube
that's on youtube wonderful um okay
let's get into these instagram questions
like i said we got a lot of really good
ones for you so i'm curious
of your answers the first question is
i'm 25
my husband is 26 we both have never
smoked the devil's lettuce before
what's the best way to do this
okay wow it's always fun having people
younger than you who are married asking
you for advice
sick well they look up to you and also
just to let you know i really admire
like the normalizing
of weed indulgence like i
i've learned over the last couple years
i'm a late comer to
uh smoking and drinking weed of all
sorts and i'm a big fan
love drinking my weed and uh
i think it's really great to normalize
it but it is
so intimidating when oh i still
feel like i like here's the thing with
it is
any drug it's like even advil is gonna
have
a different response to everybody yes
so for me i i started smoking when i was
20 like and by that i mean like i took a
hit
at a party and was like whoa oh
okay guys i probably started smoking
consistently
when i moved to l.a um
but you just i would recommend being
with people you trust
you can always get more you can never
take it out
yes yes yes yes very good advice and
just like note how you feel because
sometimes you might be really paranoid
and then that could just totally be
you being anxious before you getting a
strain that didn't work for you like
because it works differently for
everybody so with edibles
i would try like i edibles was my like
biggest battle because i was always
someone who was like [ __ ] edibles i
don't want to be high for 80 hours
because i would always be high for 80
hours
uh-huh and so then i started getting
these i
worked small to big and i got these
gummies that were 10 milligrams and i
would take
10 and then i'd be like okay in an hour
let's see how we're feeling
i can do more and then you just kind of
get to find your sweet spot
and yeah i don't
i agree it is no that's great advice
because i didn't realize
like i just assumed that weed gets you
high
that's it and that there's that
different strands didn't have different
effects
and when you actually take the time like
you said to be around people you trust
and like check in with yourself you
notice
very different things like when i first
started smoking when i was in my 20s
i hated it because i always immediately
felt like i was going to piss my pants
i had just straight paranoia straight to
pissing my pants
that i constantly be like fiddling with
my like jean buttons to make sure i
hadn't pissed myself
around people that i barely knew and so
i avoided it
all the time and only what i have no
idea and so my assumption
and then like my preconceived paranoia
so every time i smoked i was like oh god
you're gonna have those thoughts again
and only in the last like few years have
i noticed
oh how very different it is when you're
in a different mindset
and when you're with people you trust
and when you get strands or gummies or
tinctures or whatever it is that work
well with your brain
yeah and also it's just you might be at
a point where
we doesn't work for you it's like cause
like when i lived in new york i would
always
get high and then like or i would never
um
but like you know i would smoke and then
be like holy [ __ ] like
i'm afraid of the law so i would get
paranoid but when i moved here i'm like
you know like so it my i have a friend
who used to love it now
they're they get paranoid so they
stopped and then now or they used to get
paranoid and then now they're
back to finding their rhythm so just and
take your time
and also it may just not be your thing
and that's fine
totally true that is just fine and i
always want to make that clear because i
am very open with it um that like you
know
this is what i do to really i have an
overwhelming amount of anxiety
so for me it's like almost it almost
focuses me and really makes me
productive and
yeah no one i know relates to that so
it's just yeah what works for me is
different
and yeah yeah i think that's the best
advice i mean and
they'll never know until they start
experimenting with it exactly
um a lot of these questions what's your
favorite munchies snack
oh lately i've really been in the habit
of just a nice 11 30 p.m
domino's pizza hell yeah
no it's like not cute anymore it was
first out
at first it was like oh yeah now it's
like oh
no um but like takis
they're solid yeah that's a good one
a lot of questions like this how do you
deal with your mental health
in the pandemic
uh have you developed any
like self-care whatever woo of a term
that is
like little things for yourself yeah i
wake up and immediately swallow my
antidepressants
i um i see a therapist once a week
that's nice but sometimes i'm like [ __ ]
it i feel nothing
um and then like sometimes it's just
accepting
a bad day and like not trying to turn it
around which
i don't know if that's good advice but
sometimes i
find that like trying to make a shitty
day good
yeah it it's just it like makes me
more depressed i'm so with you a hundred
percent that i've
yeah done that same thing it makes a
huge difference even though it seems
really minor
that when you say i'm off today i'm
going to give myself permission to be
off today and tomorrow
we'll see what happens but yeah it
really makes a huge difference if you
can afford like
a few hours to just go okay i'm just
going to let myself feel a little bad
without trying to you don't even need to
feel bad or you don't even need to try
and fix it but just maintaining like
a neutral like you don't have to do
something you love but like if you have
a bathtub
take a hot bath and just lay there don't
bring your phone just
like take time and don't do anything
like that's okay and it's so
i don't know why it's so hard for me
specifically
to do that but like i think i yeah i
have the same kind of feelings
as you have i think a lot of people that
work in a
weird world like where we work you know
your job
doesn't clock in and clock out at a
certain time of day so technically
every hour is an opportunity to be
productive and so you
create these really uh
unfair expectations for yourself that
sometimes you're not going to meet and
that's okay
yeah this is a really sweet question
someone says the qualities he loves most
about his friends question mark
oh i love that they like me
um i like i don't know i like how
different all of my friends are and how
like how they bring a different thing
into my life to that makes it
what answer from miss america is this oh
my god you were miss new jersey
no i wasn't but i competed i yeah i i
i dabbled for a second and it is a world
that i do not thrive in i learned a lot
of
lessons yeah then got into comedy pretty
hard right after that
so if anything it really helped me find
it in a different direction
or miss new jersey launched you into
comedy yeah it gave me a good pivot
which is really good really helpful a
good heel to stand by
uh-huh uh so i want to know what makes
the perfect sweatsuit a perfect
sweatsuit
this is a good one um i think
it has to be nice and thick but not
too thick that you're constantly
sweating and
like just thick enough that it like can
kind of maintain some structure
mm-hmm and then you're like um
no you're psychotic no no no this is
actually very helpful because i've been
living in
five pieces of sweat related clothing
for the last eight months
and i need to yeah and it's all kind of
[ __ ] so i should invest in some nicer
pieces and so i'm like yeah
good french terry um i think a nice
thick french terry is good i love a nice
thick solid waistband that's elastic
yeah um
a zippered pocket um
and okay this might be controversial
some people like the jogger
ankle bands but like thick ones no i
like the
thin scrunchy elastic at the ankle i
think that's where it's at
yeah love that yeah someone says maybe
this is dumb
but like 20 21 resolutions question mark
i don't think i believe in like
resolutions i like want to
i want to be like one of those people
that's like
you know like i woke up january 1 and
i'm new
but like i just i'd rather just start
today if i have something that i want to
change
if there's something i want to do i'll
just like work at it
good for you so no yeah i'm not a
resolutions person and same thing i feel
like every year maybe i will be
and then i stop myself because i feel
like
i will inevitably not succeed at them in
some capacity and that's more
devastating
exactly exactly uh someone to know
what's the most scorpio thing he's ever
done
are you a scorpio i am i don't know what
that [ __ ]
like i don't know like i know like
scorpios are
like but like i don't [ __ ] know
what's the most scorpio thing i've done
i don't know maybe that's the most
scorpio thing
that you have no idea yeah let's
sign seal and deliver that one uh
someone asked would he ever want to
change the type of content he puts out
now this kind of goes in line with like
a bigger question i've had of you've
been doing
internet stuff for a while now yeah like
eight years
yeah how have you seen the space change
like for yourself
or for other people because to me it
feels
very obviously very different than it
did
eight years ago so different
um i this is another one where i
i don't know but i look back and i'm
like wow everything i did made sense and
like
clearly worked um or not worked but you
know like
got me by i get to see another week um
i don't i don't know just post like just
post
yeah do you work on
like do you talk to your friends about
ideas or things like that do you like
collaborate on like creative ideas in
that sense or do you just kind of do it
and then maybe they see it afterwards
dad ladder sometimes if i'm like what do
you think of this
a lot of times with title help i'll ask
friends i'll be like
which title or which thumbnail will you
click on um
but with video ideas i really kind of
just take a look at like what i put up i
i know like i like two years ago it's
like
such an era where i look at everything i
did and i was like you
are incredible like my instagram feed my
youtube channel it's just
all so oh
chef's kiss it is it was just such it
was just i was so stoked about
everything i was doing
um so no i
what was the question i'm like thinking
about this like
perfect year right no i think uh you
kind of answered it already that you
seem to do
like whatever you're feeling in the
moment and then when you look back on it
you're like yeah that made sense for me
yeah i try and find things that are
wacky and weird and
not typical because it's almost fun to
create something that's
so random yeah and then also i've just
come to like the understanding that a
lot of the time people
are like i am what makes the video
so whatever yeah so i i just know
like okay this might not be the most
stimulating or
exciting thing to shoot but have faith
that it'll turn out
yeah because it's yours yeah yeah and
like i don't i always figure it out
totally um okay last question
someone asked strategies for lockdown
i'm being super strict with myself but
running out of ideas
we're really going to end on that kind
of a note aren't we um well how have you
because
you have a roommate so you have a
lockdown buddy
have you guys started doing anything
specific or have you created any sort of
games or nights or activities
we luckily both play fortnite so
we video
it's like a cartoon like call of duty
basically it's
it's like fun i don't it's well no it
sounds fun also because you guys twitch
stream a lot right well so that is
something i've gotten into
over quarantine was like oh why don't i
figure out what the [ __ ] twitch is
yeah and that's been a really nice way
of being social of
just having like that is something i
have found that i
took for granted every day up until this
quarantine was just
having an immediate social network
on our finger to it's like we can go
live on instagram we can just
[ __ ] be bored out of our mind still
live and we have
thousands of people to talk to and and
everyone wants to talk to someone
exactly and so it's that actually has
been a really great thing
which might not be relatable to the
person who asked this
no i'd get a following in live streams
well i also think just participating in
any like i imagine you can do twitch
with people without having a major
following and still get the same sort of
uh energy of you know engaging with
people
safely totally i've been going on walks
which i
feel nice really like lucky that i'm
able to do because i think about living
in new york during all of this and i
can't imagine i just i don't i can't
imagine um
so that's i that walking being outside
has just
really been nice nice i know i've really
appreciated
nature way more this year than i've ever
before front yards
slept on slept on
uh chris this has been so fun i feel
like i could talk to you for a really
long time but we have to wrap up
but before we um wrap up completely we
give our guests a little uh token of our
appreciation for making time for us
i believe melissa has emailed you we
have a personalized fortune cookie
from us to you uh i think it's in your i
think it's in your email if you're able
to open that
oh my god let me open it
i'm like what i have a fortune cookie
to validate your thoughts and feelings
no you're not crazy people
should be wearing masks and social
distancing
they go i agree there you go
um now chris where can people find you
if they don't know where can they find
the clothing company where can they find
your twitch anything you want them to
know about
um youtube is just youtube.com chris
c-h-r-i-s
and then twitter instagram uh
chris clemons tick tock is the chris
clemons because i got a lifetime ban on
chris clemons for smoking a bong
um middle kid dot supply
is the website for clothing nice
wow i have not had to plug myself in a
long time russ i'm rusty
you do yeah that's enough one of those
you'll find me the rest
yeah i just and if you go to rosie
o'donnell's tick tock it'll lead you
back to yours
in some way shape or form oh my god
thank you chris this has been so fun
thank you this has been so
fun of course everyone make sure you go
check out everything he's up to because
truly you never know what's going to
happen next
it is a wild ride we'll see you guys
next time on another episode of not too
deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music